well religion is an interesting topic
because religion is universal all human
societies believe in the supernatural
all human societies have a village in
one way or another which for the
biologists must mean that religion has
some advantages offer some advantages to
a society otherwise we wouldn't have
that strong tendency to develop it and
so for me that's actually a far more
interesting question of whether God
exists or doesn't doesn't exist that
sort of questions I cannot answer but
the question of why we have religions is
an interesting question and my view is
that morality our human morality is
older than religion so instead of seeing
morality comes from God or religion gave
us morality for me that's a big no-no
our current religions are just two or
three thousand years old which is very
young and our species is much older and
I cannot imagine that for example a
hundred thousand years or two hundred
thousand years our ancestors did not
have some type of morality of course
they had rules about how you should
behave what is fair what is unfair
caring for others all of these
tendencies we're in place already so
they had a moral system and then at some
point we develop these present-day
religions which I think we're sort of
tacked on to the morality that we had
and maybe they serve to codify codify
them or to enforce them or to steer
morality in a particular direction that
we prefer and so religion comes in for
me secondarily I'm struggling with
whether we need religion so personally I
think we can be moral without religion
because we probably had morality long
before the current religions came along
so I think we can be moral without
religion but in large-scale societies
where we we are not all keeping an eye
on each other because we don't in
societies with a thousand people or
several thousands or millions of people
we cannot all keep an eye on each other
and that's maybe why we installed
religions in these large-scale societies
where a God kept watch over everybody
and then the question becomes is this
really needed now in northern Europe I'm
from the Netherlands that is basically
an experiment going on in Northern
Europe the majority of people are not
religious and
when you when you ask them they say
they're non-believers and they still
have a moral Society as far as I can
tell and so there is a sort of
experiment going on there can we set up
a society where religion is not dominant
at least it may be present but is not
dominant anymore that is still a moral
society and until now I think that
experiment is going pretty well and so
I'm optimistic that religion is not
strictly needed but but I cannot be a
hundred percent sure because we've never
really tried there is no human society
where religion is totally absent so we
will really have never tried this
experiment